Patrick Bach came out and they showed it
was kind of weird they showed like a
very short single player like snipe from
the trailer 15 seconds yeah you want to
sure why the false start there that was
a little odd like friggin is you with it
and then we're gonna show you the full
thing in three minutes time that's yeah
I don't quite get the whatever it
doesn't matter well what's they finally
showed the full thing look pretty cool
that we're gonna be piloting like
Zeppelin's and apparently an armored
train or by like the behemoth vehicles
sounds very cool I wonder if they'll do
anything like that 2142 titan mode where
you had like a big you know ship do you
have to like take down i wonder if and
part of the multiplayer perhaps this
trader looks alive you guys seen lebanon
that movie the non-sticky Israeli tank
movie where it all takes place inside of
a tank no kind of a lot of that
happening there would like all these
dudes crowned in there so I wonder if
maybe that's part of the single player
yeah looks great though doesn't it the
single players from different peoples
perspective right so much when you'll
get to play as the Harlem Hellfighters
how long he'll fight is the British do
he gets plays germany right no there's
like Bedouin tribes they had in like
chasing after her tray looks like desert
yes maybe not this for tactical it feels
like a heightened World War one I mean
yeah cuz we did at the start they were
like we're doing like a take on World
War one yeah yeah it's just like
obviously I think it's just them being
like we got a world in one and I do
think they've and they've already said
they've gone to a lot of effort to
research what was actually used in
combat and stuff like that and
incorporate heats that into the game but
I think it just means at the end of the
day we're playing a battlefield game
that needs to be about a full game so I
think people were quite worried did that
is that like we're so accustomed to all
the drones and the high tech that like
it would be seen as a step back and let
see slow paced on whatever but from this
trailer release from the cut of this
trailer yeah definitely I think I can
expect high energy yeah look at this
nonsense just high energy with horses
and tanks stabbing fools happen
complains I place my playground let's
friggin windmills how's that a crossbow
lots of different ability they also said
there was going to be like dynamic
weather coming into which they can
I have added into a bunch of the
battlefield 4 and maps especially the
ones in the sort of ocean wants the
island ones yeah yeah looks interesting
and I was basically that was CC a's
press conference